you're working on uh a documentary now
about nuclear energy yes so it's
interesting to talk about this energy is
such a big part of the world
about the geopolitics of the world about
the way the world is what do you think
is the role of nuclear energy in the
21st century good question and first of
all hobbies everyone's talking about
climate change right so here i wake up
to that a few years ago and
clearly we're concerned
i
picked up a book by josh goldstein and
his his co-author who's swedish those
two wrote a book called bright future a
bright future came out a few years ago
and i lapped it up it was a book
fact-based
clear
not too long and not too technical and
uh it was very clear that they were in
favor of all kinds of
renewables renewable energy yes
they hated made it very clear how
dangerous oil
and
gas were
methane
and made it very clear to the layman
like me and
at the same time said that this
renewables can work so far
but the gap is enormous as to what how
much electricity this kind of the world
is going to need
in 2050 and beyond
two three four times we don't even know
the damage but we have india we have
china we have africa we have
asia coming on to the scene wanting more
and more electricity so they addressed
the problem as a global one not just as
often in the united states you get the
ethnocentric
united states point of view that we need
we know we're doing well blah blah blah
we're not doing well but we we we we
sell that to people that were
comfortable we spent more energy than
anybody this country per capita
than anybody and at the same time
we don't seem to understand the global
picture so that's what they did and they
made me very aware so the only way to
close that gap the only way in their
mind is nuclear energy and talking about
a gap of building
a huge amount of reactors over the next
30 years
and
starting now
they make that point over and over again
so
obviously this country the united states
is not going to go in that direction
because it just
is incapable with its of having that
kind of will political will and fear is
a huge factor and still a lot of
shibboleths a lot of
myths about
nuclear energy have
confused and confounded the landscape
the environmentalists have played a huge
role
in
doing good things many good things but
also
confusing and confounding the landscape
and making accusations against nuclear
energy that were
exaggerated
so taking all these
things into consideration we set about
making this documentary which is about
finished now almost finishing it's an
hour and 40 minutes and that was a hard
part getting it down from
about three and a half hours to about
this something more manageable and is it
interviews its interviews among others
but essentially we went to russia we
went to france which is the most perhaps
advanced nuclear country in the world
russia
and the united states we went to the
idaho laboratory
and talked to the uh
the scientists there as well as the
department of energy people that are
handling this idaho is one of the
experimental labs the united states is
probably one of the most advanced and
they're doing a lot of advanced nuclear
there
we also uh
we studied uh well russia gave us a lot
of uh insight we were very cooperative
because they have some of the most
advanced uh nuclear
actually the probably most advanced
nuclear reactor in the world the
bellairs the ural mountains
so we we did an investigation there
and uh in france they haven't they have
some very advanced uh
nuclear reactors and they're building
and now they're building again
they had a little the green party came
into power and just not into power but
became a factor in france and there was
a motion when hollande was president
they started to move away from it
actually they were beginning to just
abandon
they let not complete their in other
words let close down some of the nuclear
reactors there was talk of that but
thank god france did not do that and uh
macron came in and
recently reversed it it reversed it and
they're building as fast as they can now
especially with the ukraine war
uh going on there's an awareness that
russia will not be providing or may not
be providing the energy europe needs
so
and then china is the other one too
that's the other factor i'm talking
about the big boys
they have doing tremendous work and fast
which is very hopeful
but of course china is building in all
directions at once the coal continues to
be huge in china
and
uh
methane too but to basically colder coal
in india in china are the biggest users
of coal
um and we know as you know germany went
back to coal uh a few years ago so all
these factors it's fascinating picture
globally so we try to achieve a
consensus that where nuclear can work
and where it will be working worse and
it will be used more and more the
question is how much carbon dioxide
china
and russia will be putting out france is
the only one that's not putting it out
the united states has not changed with
all the talk and all the nonsense about
renewables and
the new lifestyle and all this it's it's
great for your guilt complex but it
doesn't do anything for the total commun
accumulation of carbon dioxide in the
world who's going to lead the way on
nuclear do you think you mentioned
russia france china united states who's
going to live i don't think it's going
to be a uni united nations kind of thing
because the world doesn't seem capable
of uniting we don't we go to these
conferences
kyoto and
we talk and we agree but then we don't
actually enforce so i don't think it can
happen that way i think it's
going to be an individual race with
countries they're going to just be do it
for their own self-interest like china
is doing it
china
the thing is if it works and i'm praying
that it will really work on a big scale
china will back away from coal naturally
the same thing will be true of india
they will see the benefits because if
you go to india you see the cities the
pollution you walk around in that stuff
and you know you get
it's it's not there's no
hope in this and you sense it so people
will move in this direction naturally
because nuclear is clean energy
and the amount of
casualties of nuclear is the lowest on
the industrial scale for energy
producing
from coal down to oil everything the
lowest casualty rate
very low is .002 or something is nuclear
so uh not that many people have died
from nuclear not that many i think
50 people at chernobyl which was the
worst accident
nobody died at fukushima nobody died at
three mile island and that's what you
hear all over and over again these these
accidents
the environmentalists have sold us the
idea that they're dangerous
and it's a lot of environmentalists
thank god of changing it they've come
off that routine and they've seen
this we were wrong we've done a lot of
good work greenpeace did a lot of good
work whale
whales saving this saving that
but
they admit themselves not they don't but
uh people who have been in the
organization
have said we were wrong
in 1956
we show the
the articles in the new york times that
came out the rockefeller foundation
which of course is a big
producer of oil
the rockefeller family and
the foundation came out uh
with a uh study
which was weighted they tipped the scale
uh put a thumb on the scale but it was a
scientific
expose of radiation in the uh in the in
the study that came out in the printed
in the new york times because the new
york times publisher salzburger was on
their board he was one of them at board
members
so they got a lot of
strong publicity
condemning radiation from which killed
started the process of doubting nuclear
energy the radiation levels that they
pointed out were very minor
and of course if you go into a
scientific analysis of this now with
what we know it's just not true
but it it tilted the scale back in the
50s 60s and started the question
questioning the nuclear
business do you think that was
malevolence or incompetence no i think
it was competition
i don't think it was conspiracy as much
as it was a sense we don't want this
nuclear energy is going to end the the
dominance of oil absolutely and it will
and it will anyway because it's the only
sane way for the world to proceed but
the world
will have to learn through
adversity
so in other words the situation could
get worse
much worse and certain countries are
just going to have to adapt like we
always do when things become too hard
you've got to go you have to change your
thinking
and humans are pretty good at that yes
talking about human nature they're very
adept at that
germany for example i mean they were
when the fukushima happened they went
out of the nuclear business that was
shocking to me
uh they just pulled out and they
destroyed uh
destructed several of their nuclear
reactors who were still functioning and
put up coal
or or yeah put up coal and oil
replaced it and as a result
germany uh drifted into this place next
to france their con their electricity
bills went up and france stayed the same
they don't have that they have a
different system in europe but you know
more or less no question that france was
doing a lot better than germany and uh
now when with this ukraine issue it's a
very interesting fulcrum point whether
germany is what what direction they're
going to go now
how can they
how can they keep going with coal they
just can't
you